So ABC's Martha Raddatz interviewed some Trump
supporters who I guess are covid, skeptical,
mask's, skeptical and just generally not very
informed people.
And it's really bad.
And there's is a huge controversy that has
surfaced as to whether this is even something
that should have been done at all.
I'm going to play a clip for you here and
then we'll talk about it.
It's important to understand these are not
just Trump supporters.
These are Trump supporters who downplay the
pandemic to some degree, who either refuse
to wear masks or don't think it's quite so
serious.
And remember, we now regularly are having
over 150000 cases a day.
We're back up to 1500 deaths per day.
These are folks who aren't so sure it's serious,
even though more than 250000 Americans have
already died.
Let's take a look.
Eriksson's in the aftermath of the election,
I found many who continue to downplay the
pandemic.
Do you not wear a mask because Donald Trump?
No, absolutely not.
No, because that's that's that's.
I just don't believe in.
Same thing with me.
I mean, can the masks really defend a microbe
coming through the weaving of the fiber?
I doubt it.
I really doubt it.
You guys just not believe the scientists on
this?
No, I believe covid covered.
It's real and covered is absolutely right.
Just like I said, I just lost my cousin.
You know, I never thought that the disease
was worth all the precautions and everything
that went down as far as shutting down the
country.
Even though you're worried about this virus,
how do you feed your family?
I'm more worried about that than I am about
catching something that has like was a ninety
seven point nine five percent survival rate.
Wash your hands, eat well, take probiotics
and your vitamins.
You know, just do what we do during cold and
flu season and just pray for the best.
OK, so I don't believe in masks.
What does that mean?
You don't believe they exist?
You don't believe that they do anything?
Oh, well, then I don't believe masks work.
Based on what?
And that's my complaint with this, because
there's been this huge controversy over the
responsibility or irresponsibility of platforming
these people.
The idea being we know dumb people exist,
we know ignorant people exist.
We know, you know, a hyper partizan people
exist who will believe anything Trump says.
And what are we really getting out of this?
I have talked before about the term responsible
platforming.
I've interviewed Trump supporters, support,
you know, white nationalists, homophobes,
whatever.
My view has always been, you have to do it
responsibly where if you're going to air people
saying irresponsible things, they must be
made to appear irresponsible and ignorant
and unhinged.
And sometimes it's a matter of just asking
questions.
Right.
If you're going to do this, you have to follow
up the question.
When someone says, I don't believe masks work,
you say, how did you determine that masks
don't work?
Why do you know more than epidemiologists?
What is your job?
What is your education?
The woman who says, you know, take your probiotics
and your vitamins and pray to God that you
don't get the virus.
Why do you need prayer?
If probiotics and vitamins work?
What evidence do you have that probiotics
and vitamins prevent coronavirus?
If you need the probiotics and vitamins, why
is it that you also need to pray?
Right?
I mean, come on, guys.
I actually question doing this.
If you're not going to provide that environment.
We know there are dumb people out there, but
what we are doing here, if you don't do this
responsibly, the way it should be done is
you are giving these people credibility as
legitimate participants among adult conversations
when they're not, you know, people who think
if you cut taxes for the rich, it stimulates
the economy.
That's a topic that's worthy of a discussion.
Even if they are wrong.
There's, you know, a legitimate debate there.
They're wrong, but it's not irresponsible
the way this is irresponsible.
This is like disaster porn.
But what's the point if you're not going to
ostracize these people or give them enough
rope to ostracize themselves, so to speak,
especially since Trump lost.
And so I'm not going to play more clips because
you clearly get the picture of this.
I don't want to give these people more attention,
but of course, I have no problem interviewing
dumb people or even people with dangerous
or bad ideas.
I've done it many, many times.
But to do it, you have to do it responsibly
and you have to actually be giving these people
the right rope with which they would hang
themselves.
When the woman says prayer and probiotics
and vitamins, you've got to be there and say,
would prayer alone work?
Why have so many Christians died?
Did they not pray hard enough?
What's the role of prayer?
Does it work to prevent other diseases like
cancer?
Could prayer prevent a car accident or cause
you to regrow a limb that had to be amputated?
You have to be an.
Actually ready and when when you know, when
the guys say, I don't think the masks are
justified based on the risk, ask if they wear
seat belts, do you pay attention to food expiration
dates?
Explain how they came to these conclusions,
whether they even reasoned their way in or
not, because they didn't.
These are people who, upon the latest questioning,
fall apart.
That's what I regret that Martha Raddatz didn't
do.
Had she done it, I would have been completely
on board with this segment.
Sadly, she handled it in a different way.